the Joe Rogan experience you did it in
terms of like if you're a young fighter
and you've got aspirations what do you
want to do you want to be an Olympic
gold medalist you want to win multiple
world titles to division world champion
and you retired undefeated you you're
the one you're like a unicorn man you
have rare dude because if you retired at
35 right 33 33 yeah that's crazy like
you're in the peak of your athletic
abilities and you go you know what I did
enough I'm out yeah I mean it sounds it
sounds all neaten buttoned up but it
wasn't it wasn't that easy like I didn't
know how things were gonna go throughout
the course of my career before whatever
reason like always even as a young kid
I'm talking ten years old like I had
this thought like you know I don't want
to end up like a lot of fighters end up
like I seem to go high really high and
then all of a sudden they come crashing
down like they start will but they don't
end well yeah that's what drew me to Roy
Jones jr. country boy had swag and he'd
always talked about himself in the third
person he'd be like man you know Roy
Jones I don't you know I don't love the
sport like that man I'm getting to get
out I'm just special at it and I'm gonna
be fishing on my farm one you know one
day a pisser called Florida I was like
man this dude is different fighters
don't talk like that
and so he was the first one that gave me
the thought of getting in and getting
out and then again I just I just studied
it throughout the course of my career
even other athletes and entertainers
like I just I was enamored by it so that
was always a goal just as much as I
wanted to win a gold medal World
Championship I wanted to leave on top
when people were asking why are you
leaving yeah it's so difficult to make
that decision though for something bro
Jones jr. didn't even make that decision
he said he was gonna do it and then I
mean he had some rough knockouts late
and it's hard to watch that
some of them that people even didn't
even see yeah yeah heartbreaking yes if
you followed him and supported him like
I have especially if you know his
decision was based on Jeremy Cleland a
lot of it was yeah yeah when Jeremy
Cleland for people don't know was a
murderer man he was a savage light
heavyweight but he caught he was cutting
a lot of weight
and you know he wound up having a
serious brain injury and in in that epic
fight with Nigel Benner is an amazing
amazing fight would been got off the
deck it looked like the fight was over
because general McClellan would just
murk people man absolutely like a
prototypical crunk destroyer you know a
right hand
woo tall strong as [ __ ] super aggressive
knockout striker and for whatever reason
Roy decided you know what let's just
keep doing it yeah it's a lot of
different reasons why people do that man
I just didn't want to be one of them
simply simply put but it is like the
retirement is coming up on two years
September 21st it's harder than I
thought it was gonna be one of the most
hardest things I've ever had to do but
one of the most rewarding and the way I
reconcile it and my brain is that okay
at some point I'm I have to do this at
some point I'm about to face the
emotions and in the pool to come back
and you know trying to figure out if
your body can still do it and just all
the different things you go through
whether I'm in my prime or rather I'm
4045 years old so you can't avoid it
it's just when do you want to take take
on that task so you retired at 33 35 now
so god damn man you're right there
I mean you've like four more years to be
unless you're Bernard Hopkins then you
have another decade but to Banaras
credit he started late he didn't are
started at 20-some years old and graded
from state prison yeah I started at 9
years old